it's the group at the center of major
conspiracy theories they've been accused
of pulling the strings of major
governments around the world for
inserting symbols into such prominent
places as the US dollar bill and
conspiracy theorists have claimed that
everyone from the Beatles to Tom Brady
to Kanye West are more recent members of
the centuries-old Society
there's no doubt the Illuminati have
impacted world affairs even if just by
being at the center of conspiracy
theories but where did this group get
its start well let's take a look at the
man behind this secretive Society Johann
Adam Weiss ups
[Music]
Johann Adam white who was born into an
academic household in Bavaria he came
into the world on February the 6th 1748
is the son of a law professor when why
South was only 5 years old his father
passed away leaving him to be raised by
his grandfather also a law professor
Weiss helps grandfather kept the boy
engaged in scholastic activities his
grandfather was a proponent of the
Enlightenment movement in the thoughts
and philosophies promoted by
Enlightenment thinkers came to greatly
influenced Weiss house during the 17th
and 18th century Enlightenment movement
intellectuals emphasized the importance
of Reason and individualism over
tradition you might also hear the
Enlightenment referred to as the age of
reason among the movements most famous
thinkers were John Locke and Isaac
Newton when he was seven years old Weiss
harps education expanded beyond his
grandfather's teaching the family was
Catholic and white helped began
attending a Jesuit school he was a
voracious reader and by the time he was
20 years old he had earned his doctorate
in law he began teaching law bars within
a year he became the beneficiary of the
dissolution of the very religious order
that had educated him political
maneuvering coupled with cultural
changes made the Jesuits a threat to the
power of some European leaders at least
in their eyes the order was suppressed
in several countries and even the Pope
issued a brief suppressing the Jesuits
because of the order's suppression in
1773 Weiss helped was able to move from
being a professor of secular law to
being a professor of Canon Law at the
University of Ingolstadt before the
suppression only Jesuits thwart canon
law now Weiss Hobbes could be a
professor but he nonetheless found
himself as the only non clergy member
serving as such although the order had
been suppressed
they still wielded considerable power at
the University and Weiss Hart and his
enlightenment influenced ideas well they
hit some roadblocks as a result ice
helped grew to dislike clerics he was
frustrated and he wanted a way to spread
the words of the Enlightenment without
being stonewalled by the church
so he decided to start his own society
BAM what was the goal of this society
this is the great object held out by
this association and the means of
attaining it is illumination
enlightening the understanding by the
Sun of Reason which will dispel the
clouds of superstition and of prejudice
initially why sub didn't want to start
his own secret society he had wanted to
join the Freemasons a group that he
thought wouldn't line up nicely with his
passion for reason over religion but
ultimately he decided that the
Freemasons weren't exactly what he
wanted and so he took the leap and
started his own society he did look to
the Freemasons for inspiration in
rituals and organizational structure
though over time especially after I
stopped ended up joining the Freemasons
the two groups became more linked in the
minds of many especially conspiracy
theorists to start his society why salps
began reaching out to like-minded men he
had befriended at university but they
had to be young men anyone over 30 was
just too unlikely to be influenced by
new ideas and white Supt
he wanted the men who joined to be true
believers in the Enlightenment ready to
start spreading the ideals of reason and
spreading them as high up as they could
the group of men first met in May of
1776 only five of them arrived in the
forest that first night carrying torches
and ready to embark on their quest to
spread their ideas to the world to be
initiated into the Illuminati why some
wanted his members to experience being
reborn this way they would be leaving
behind their lives before joining the
Illuminati and be able to fully immerse
themselves in their commitment to the
new secret society the initiation rite
included sacrifices and mystical
elements who did men unknown identities
and darkened rooms are hallmarks of such
rights claims have been made that the
Illuminati initiation rites have taken
the sacrifice element to its most
extreme stage the sacrificing of an
actual human being to be initiated and
reborn the idea is that the new member
would have to experience death and be
reborn and actually killing someone
would give them an insight into the
experience of death but the initiation
rite is also said
have given many members the experience
of death and rebirth through the killing
of an animal
the Illuminati would put an animal on
top of the new member kill the animal
and just let it bleed to death on top of
the new member soaking in the animals
blood encouraged rebirth and the
understanding of life death and
knowledge overall wite-out did not want
the Illuminati to remain just a small
academic society that operated in an
echo chamber though he wanted it to
reach the highest echelon of society
with members both influencing political
leaders and even becoming political
leaders themselves but he also didn't
want the society to grow full of men he
couldn't trust and who weren't truly
dedicated to the course so the men have
met that first night which have to be
agreed to by the five members present at
night as well as prove themselves to be
from families of high standing and
wealth the latter two requirements would
help with wise hearts goal to get his
ideas moving up the societal ladder and
into the minds of intellectual families
and society now the order's famous name
it didn't come to us helped right away
the first name for his secretive group
was the perfectibility an aim that they
actually stuck with for two years the
idea that a man is perfectible was part
of the group's ideals even american
founding father thomas jefferson
appreciated this trait of whiteouts and
his ideas stating why self seems to be
an enthusiastic philanthropist he is
among those as you know the excellent
Richard Price and Priestley also are who
believe in the indefinite perfectibility
of man he thinks he may in time be
rendered so perfect that he will be able
to govern himself in every circumstance
so as to engine none to do all the good
he can to leave government have no
occasion to exercise their powers over
him and of course to render political
government useless before the name
Illuminati was officially adopted why
stopped also thought about naming the
group the B order births illuminati was
ultimately decided upon and why saps
took the owl as the group's symbol so
now you might be wondering well why did
he choose now what exactly is the
significance of this bird now Minerva
the goddess of wisdom was accompanied by
an owl the owl was away for Weiss helped
to indicate the intellectual basis for
the secret society while still keeping
its symbol
just a bit coded the new name was a
callback to the occult beliefs within
the Spanish culture during medieval
times alchemists and magicians were
believed to be imbued with a light that
signified the presence of a higher power
within within the society the members
took nicknames Weiss helps as the head
of the order was Spartacus while other
adopted names for members included Ajax
and Tiberius in 1777 Weiss helped found
a new avenue for recruiting he was
accepted into a Freemasons group in
Germany and used their society as a
place to find well-connected society men
who were already acquainted with and
interested in secret societies the men
who were welcomed in we're told the
following should you seek might power
false honor excess seek that we would
work for you to provide your temporal
advantages we will bring you as close to
the throne as you wish and then turn you
over to the consequences of your folly
but our inner sanctuary remains closed
to such but should you want to learn
wisdom want to learn to make mankind
more clever better free and happy then
be thrice welcomed by us the men who
joined Weiss helps newfound order found
themselves a part of a group that was
split into distinct levels as much as
Weiss helped to profess the principles
of rationalism and individualism related
to the Enlightenment movement the men
who were a part of his fault were
restricted in their knowledge about what
was going on within their own
organization the Illuminati had a
hierarchy within the structure and the
members at the bottom reported to those
at the top there were three ranks of men
novice Minerva and illuminated Minerva
illuminating Minerva were at the top of
the Illuminati's pecking order their
name inspired by the Roman goddess of
wisdom they spied on each other and on
the political and economic goings-on in
society bringing news back to the order
and helping the Illuminati move forward
in its goals of influencing the top
tiers of society
do you realize sufficiently what it
means to rule to rule in a secret
society not only over the lesser or more
importance of the populace but over the
best of men over men of all ranks
nations and religions to rule without
external force to unite them in
dishonourably to breathe one spirit and
soul into them men distributed over all
parts of the world in his first years
the Illuminati
it didn't grow by leaps and bounds
initially they found only a few dozen
interested and qualified men to join
they numbered just 60 by 1780 but that
year white helped added a member to the
Illuminati who proved himself to be
especially helpful in gaining new
members and he also attracted a new
level of respect for the secret society
and this new member he came from why
saps recruiting grounds in the
Freemasons barren and off-key nigga had
been a member of the Freemasons but he
had risen as far as he could go within
their ranks so when he heard of Weiss
apt and his new smaller group he saw an
opportunity to have real sway over what
was going on in the organization he also
liked the Illuminati's relationship with
mysticism in forming the order Weiss
Alton relied in part on mystic texts he
read the mysteries of the seven sages of
Memphis and the Kabbalah and the two
texts made an impact on how he viewed
the world around him Baron Koenig was
also a student of such ideas and liked
that Weiss helped had brought their
influence into the Illuminati when he
joined can I get easily read the texts
required of new members most consisted
of works that were banned in the
conservative catholic bavaria in fact
can ago read the text so quickly that
weiss helped had to stall for time he
didn't want Knigge to reach the
illuminated minerva level so quickly so
he put off gonnago while he tried to
come up with new ideas for readings and
required actions but Knigge figured out
that Weiss helped was trying to delay
his achievements of the highest level
when he brought this up to Weiss helped
wise helped was willing to listen
he was also willing to listen to connect
his new ideas for the order for one
coneja said the order needed a
rearrangement of its hierarchy he
suggested bringing in new levels under
the existing three levels the end result
of this was 13 ranks of Illuminati
members each subdivided within the
original three levels the three new
overarching levels had the names of the
nursery the Masonic grades and the
mysteries Knigge also used his influence
to change wise how strong messaging
about the church and about religion he
realized that such a strong stance might
be hampering the group's ability to grow
and recruit new and powerful members
after all the church wielded much power
in bavaria in the 18th century and even
the promise that a society was secret
might not be strong enough for sure
four men from powerful families to risk
joining why SERPs listened to Canoga and
the illuminati they benefited from an
organization of just sixty they grew to
two hundred by seventeen eighty two then
the group grew to three thousand members
by 1784 the Illuminati had also spread
beyond bavaria membership now included
Hungary Poland and Italy but having that
many members spread throughout a number
of countries made it harder and harder
to keep things quiet and if their very
purpose was to infiltrate and influence
political thought and actions then of
course the upper echelon of society
would start to notice them
[Applause]
in 1784 their growth became a problem
members of the Illuminati were sending
correspondence back and forth and the
government have their eye out for it
writings with internal Illuminati ideas
and policies were intercepted in Bavaria
it's also been thought that this
interception was set up by this point
wise HAP's had some disgruntled members
within his ranks when Weiss helped first
started the organization he told some
members there would be supernatural
communication if they achieved the
highest level within the society but
plenty of people had achieved this by
1784 and there was no supernatural
communication to be had baron Knigge and
Weiss helped they also had a major
disagreement they didn't have the same
idea about some of the society's rituals
and their arguments culminated in Canada
leaving the secret society the same year
he left the Illuminati the Bavarian
government banned all secret societies
that was in 1784 which was the same year
that the membership had exploded by the
next year the Bavarian government took
it a step further they banned the
Illuminati specifically as part of the
Illuminati's banishment the government
began raiding the documents of known
Illuminati documents started to be
published and this secret society and
its membership there wasn't so secret
anymore
public officials became known as members
putting their livelihoods and societal
rankings on the line the Illuminati
simply couldn't function with its
membership being known throughout all of
this society building and government
influencing Weiss helped had still been
working as a professor at the University
of English dart but when the government
banned the Illuminati he was forced to
flee as home and leave behind his job
Weiss elves
wasn't kind to the government to
government of any sort not just Bavaria
so it is not surprising that they were
not pleased with his writings so just
how strongly did he feel about the
government well take this quote when man
lives under government he has fallen his
worth is gone and his nature tarnished
when the Illuminati were bands from
Bavaria Weiss out was forced to flee to
go to another part of Germany there
white helped was protected by a
sympathetic Duke Duke Ernest not only
provided political protection for Weiss
helped but he also gave him the pension
that allowed him to live without working
even though the Illuminati had been
disbanded in Bavaria Weiss Alps kept
pushing the ideas that had led him to
start the secret society in the first
place he began writing ultimately
publishing four books about the history
of the Illuminati and defending its
existence the books were intended both
to defend himself and he perhaps
encouraged new growth for the Illuminati
in the province of Goethe but when Weiss
helped passed away in 1830 the
Illuminati had all but disappeared from
the world stage it's not easy to operate
even as a secret society when major
world powers they simply want you gone
while the Illuminati may have
disappeared at least in membership in
Europe the group by no means disappeared
from the world's imagination and
conversations based on today's
conspiracy theories and the prevalence
of the Illuminati and pop culture it can
be argued that why Sam succeeded in
creating a secret society that had an
influence on the world Dan Brown's
massively popular novels featured the
Illuminati in angels and demons Brown
pits the Illuminati against the Catholic
Church in a modern setting throughout
the book they use churches and artwork
to commit atrocities relying heavily on
coded symbolism then there's the
Illuminatus trilogy books that claimed
George Washington was actually replaced
by a member of the Illuminati they claim
that this imposter actually ran the
United States people even suggest that
the I on the American one dollar bill is
an indication of Illuminati interference
in American government white helps and
the Illuminati are also used in video
games and comic books and even rap songs
they're a regular feature on History
Channel shows and mysterious shows about
conspiracies from all around the world
when major events happen think that JFK
assassination and 9/11 the Illuminati
name still gets tossed around as a
possible course and there's even a
theory that the modern-day Illuminati
are now headquartered not in Bavaria
where it was founded but right in the
heart of the United States not in
Washington DC not in New York not in Los
Angeles but in Denver hidden beneath the
airport in the Colorado City is said to
be the headquarters for the modern-day
incarnation of the most powerful secret
society in the world everything from the
airport's runway design to its
underground tunnels have been pointed to
as evidence for why it's a perfect site
for the Society's operation it seems
that two hundred and fifty years after
Weiss helped first launched his idea for
a secret society his influence is
still felt from pop culture to events of
historic magnitude the Illuminati is
still a factor at least in terms of
people bringing up their name now it
might not be exactly what he was
planning well maybe it was do we really
know how a secret society operates and
has influence I mean by some did plan
for the Illuminati to operate in the
backgrounds after all so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
s-- if you did there's a couple of
things you could do right now one is hit
that like button below also if you want
more stuff like this we put out brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching